oh this is Hank green I'm at my friend
Dave Llosa's apartment because as some
of you may know I don't have a
television make it somewhat difficult to
watch debates but for the occasions in
which I do need to watch television date
is always here for me he says he doesn't
want to be on camera I'm just leaving
him over there
I spend most of my time thinking about
the environment / about young people
because for some reason I've gotten
myself into both of those camps I'm the
founder and sort of chief editor of eco
geek tour where we talk about clean
technology so obviously there was a lot
of good stuff in this debate for me but
for some reason I couldn't talk about
the young people today run this video
blog called Brotherhood 2.0 or we talk
about being nerds and it's watched by
lots of young people and they're
emailing me all the time and one of the
things that I hear and is sort of
extraordinarily encouraging is young
people saying man I wish I could vote
you know I never remembered thinking
anything anything any near that
patriotic when I was the in person I was
like man I wish I could drink more
Mountain Dew Tom Brokaw asked a question
that was sent in via the internet by a
78 year old woman interesting that a 78
year old woman can use the internet when
John McCain can't after an incredibly
good question basically saying why is it
that American never asks for any
sacrifice from its people except from
young men and women who have to go die
somewhere why can't they ask for a
sacrifice that doesn't involve guns and
John McCain answered this question by
saying sacrifices I'm gonna ask for
viewers may be cutting spending on
something isn't a sacrifice for me and
then Barack Obama says yes yes I am
gonna ask for sacrifices from the
American people I'm gonna ask for people
to use less energy I'm gonna increase
the amount of people that will enroll in
the Peace Corps I'm gonna do these
things where people especially young
people are going to be able to do things
for their country instead of you know
after 9/11 go out and shop so as much as
there was a huge amount of vitally
important stuff going on in this debate
that was the question that sort of rang
true to me the most especially hearing
from so many young people who just don't
know how they can serve their country
aside from with a gun